hello welcome to my video series of mall
bio explained in three minutes where i
explain the concept of molecular biology
in three minutes or so if you
haven't yet subscribed to the channel
hit that subscribe button
today we'll talk about colony pcr which
is a method
for rapidly screening colonies of
bacteria that have grown up
in a selective media after a
transformation process and our goal is
to identify
whether it has a desired genetic
construct or not
so let's say we have done a cloning
reaction
and in that ligation mix we would have
a self-ligated plasmid and a combination
of
recombinant plasmid and our goal is to
look at that after transformation
the colonies that appears on a plate
which of them
are recombinant and which of them don't
have the plasmid
because we are going to work with the
colonies which would have the
recombinant plasmid right
so here is the work first you have to do
the restriction and ligation
then taking this particular uh
cloned plasmid you are going to
transform it
inside a competent bacteria and then
you have to wait for overnight and in
the next day
you would generally see colonies in the
plate now some of these colonies might
have that
construct that you are looking at so
what you can do
is pick up many colonies as many as
possible from the plate
now for simplicity we are only picking
up three colonies
and try to understand whether the
recombinant construct is there or not
so we would first scrape out
a little portion of these colonies with
the help of sterilized pipet
and put it in pcr strips
we would do the same for coloring number
two and three as well
then we would prepare a master mix which
would have all the pcr components like
forward primer which we would forward
and reverse primer which we would
use to detect our construct and then
there would be dntp tag ball and
all other components of the buffer
finally
we would set the pcr reaction and place
it into the pcr machine
then while we run the gel we would get
to know
whether our recombinant construct was
present
or not in this particular example it
seems
that we get a positive band in colony
number two but we don't see it in column
number one and three
that means column number two is our
target and this has
the clone construct
so now what we are going to do go back
to the plate
and scrape a little bit of color number
two again
and then inoculate that in our test tube
containing bacterial culture media
and our goal is to amplify this
particular
bacteria and isolate the pure plasmid
from that
and lastly sequence that plasmid to
understand whether the insert has
incorporated in an in-frame situation or
not so all of these
question can be asked with sequencing
experiments
but in this video we'll learn how colony
pcr can give give us a overall idea that
whether
our plasmid of interest is incorporated
into a bacterial colony or not it's
cheap
robust and time saving so if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up you
can support me on patreon or in vmupi
and you can take my unacademic course
by using my code a p10 you get that 10
discount thank you for listening thank
you